euh sur Le Cam Guillaume Meuris hein
cette
humoriste si on peut dire humoriste euh
de France interre qui a suscité un tolé
dimanche dernier euh alors on va revir
encore la vidéo parce que cette phrase a
suscité de nombreuses réactions dont
celle du député eren Thomas ménager qui
a qualifié Guillaume meurrice de jod
doné du service public payé par nos
empôts et dans un instant nous aurons
avec nous sur le plateau un un
administrateur du Radio France Jérémy
Patrier lus euh qui est député horizon
et qui va nous en dire plus sur cette
affaire puisque euh gu Meurice a réagi
en plus hein il a il a il a continué en
fait dans dans dans son idée et c'est
vrai qu'il a il a il a réagi sur les
réseaux sociaux Guillaume MERIS il un
petit peu acculé en ce moment regardez
on va revoir la vidéo si vous l'avez pas
encore vu c'est vrai qu'on a jamais
autant parler de lui hein parce que je
pense que en notoriété c'était pas en
notoriété il était il était c'était pas
ah non mais c'est vrai c'était pas
l'indon et puis maintenant c'est c'est
toujours pas non c'est toujours pas
regardez alors halloween halloween
approche tout le monde commence à
chercher un déguisement pour faire peur
alors en ce moment il y a le déguisement
netaniaahou qui marche pas mal pour
faire peur vous voyez qui c'est une
sorte de naz mais sans prépu voilà alors
il fait pas peur à il fait pas peur à
tout le
monde en tout cas les gens on réagit
voilà donc c'était cette vidéo doncon a
déjà montré dans l'émission nombreuses
de nombreuses réactions et Guillaume
mauris a réagi on va d'abord regarder la
réaction de Thomas ménager regarder et
après on verra ce qu' Guillaume merice
qui m'inquiète aujourd'hui c'est
l'importation de ce conflit en France
c'est les manifestations antisémites qui
peuvent exercer c'est ce que Gilles kpel
appelle le le le djihadisme d'atmosphère
qu'on voit sur tout qu'on voit sur
toutes les sphères on le voit même
excusez-moi monsieur le baron mais moi
je suis quand même aussi étonné on le
voit même sur votre antenne monsieur
meuce qui il y a de jours a voulu faire
un peu le dieu donné du service public
qui est sur votre antenne qui est payé
par le service public et qui a tenu des
propos antisémites alors Guillaume Meiss
a réagit tout toujours intéressant
d'avoir la vie sur l'antisémitisme d'un
représentant d'un parti créé par des SS
alors il y a énormément de réactions et
on voulait absolument avoir la réaction
aussi de Jérémy patri letus député
horizon du Calvados et vous êtes
administrateur de Radio France tout à
fait donc c'est assez intéressant
d'avoir votre avis sur sur ce qui s'est
passé parce que on va revenir sur et
vous allez me dire ce que vous en pensez
de la sur la réaction de la direction de
France Inter dans un instant mais déjà
vous sur sur ça Jérémy Patrier lus sur
ça en tant qu'administrateur de Radio
France est-ce que vous vous cautionnez
est-ce que vous dites que c'est de
l'humour ou est-ce que vous dites c'est
inadmissible je vais vous répondre perz
en deux mots vous dire pourquoi j'ai
accepté votre invitation parce qu'on
s'est demandé pourquoi un député
administrateur de Radio France venait
sur votre antenne il y a deux raisons la
première c'est que je suis
administrateur de Radio France je suis
attaché audiovisuel public on pourra en
discuter et je pense que c'est important
et que Guillaume Meuris d'une certaine
manière nuit à ce que fait le service
public et essaie de faire le service
public la deuxième raison c'est je crois
la diversité de l'information et des
médiia et je n'ai pas accepté le
boycotte l'appel au boycotte de votre
émission et je suis là aussi en tant que
députés je pense qu'on peut être en
désaccord avec ce que vous pouvez
défendre on peut être en désaccord avec
ce que certains médias défendent mais je
pense et je le dis aux jeunes qui nous
écoutent on ne peut pas dans notre pays
boycotter des émissions ou des médias
c'est vrai pour vous c'est vrai pour
France interre quand j'entend des gens
dire faut boycotter France interre on a
besoin de cette diversité médias c'est
pour ça aussi que j'ai accepté votre
invitation et je voulais vous le dire
bien de le dire bravo jéy et
jéréyir sur ce que vous dites on peut ne
pas être d'accord avec nous ne pas être
d'accord avec moi sur plein de séquences
sur des choses et cetera mais là en
l'occurrence ne pas être d'accord avec
une émission qui prendne la paix sur ce
sur ce point-là là c'est c'est que c'est
vraiment il y a y a un énorme problème
sur d'autres sur d'autres séquences de
l'émission je peux comprendre qu'il y a
des gens qui soient pas d'accord et
cetera sur cette séquence là c'est quand
même problématique voilà c'est très
dangereux quand on en vient dans un pays
à boycotter des médias est-ce qu'on veut
devenir la socié américaine regardez les
gens de gauche regardent ces news les
gens de droites regardent Fox News c'est
ça qu'on veut dans notre pays on veut
que les gens de gauche regardent des
certains médias les gens de droite il
faut la diversité des médias moi je me
réjouis qu'un député rassemblement
national a été invité à France interre
apr
voilà
et c'est surtout sur les réseaux sociaux
mais c'est vrai que
boycotter la paix c'est assez assz
problématique bon sinon sur sur le cas
guillaumeurce vous avez dit y un instant
monsieur le député vous avez dit que il
nuisait au au service public au valeurs
du service public moi je crois que le
problème de Guillaume murce c'est pas ce
qu'un humoriste peut dire moi on pourra
en discuter je pense qu'un humoriste
peut tout dire et c'est pas la question
la question c'est à quel moment on n
plus un humoriste et on devient un
militant politique et c'est ça la
question moi c'est ce que j'ai écrit
dans dans mon courrier à la Présidente
c'est pas de mettre des limites à la
liberté d'expression la loi enose on l'a
vu avec l'affaire Dieu donné mais c'est
est-ce que quelqu'un qui sur son compte
Twitter toute la journée exprime des
opinions politiques peut ensuite se
cacher derrière l'humour pour avoir des
propos aussi scandaleux qu'il a tenu et
c'est important parce que c'est pas ici
un combat contre la liberté d'expression
moi je suis attaché à la liberté
d'expression au droit à l'humour au
droit à la satire des proches qui
disaent on peut de tout mais on peut pas
quand on a des expressions politiques
quand d'une certaine manière on est un
militant politique se cacher derrière
l'humour pour ensuite dire qu'on est un
humoriste l'humour en fait c'est
militant c'estàdire que l'humour de par
son essence c'est militant et tous les
chroniqueurs à la radio ont toujours ont
toujours été quelque part politisés ont
fait passer leur messages politiqu à
travers leur humour on peut pas demander
à un humoriste
d'avoir je par je parle de ce type
d'humoriste chroniqueur à la radio à la
télé généralement quand on fait de
l'humour il y a souvent un aspect
politique et on peut lire à travers ce
que
dit
exactement question je TR pas drôleut g
malureus r dans la limite de ce qui est
autorisé dans la limite de ce que
convient de ce que de ce que dit la
charte par toi tu es que gasparous
politiquement par pas c'est pas alors
c'est pas militant CASP pr rien à voir
il est beaucoup plus proche
d' de gu et puis Gaspar pr je vais te
dire l'avantage de Gaspar pr c'est pour
ça qu'on le on lui pardonne tout c'est
qu'il est très drôle je suis désolé
c'est comme Pierre des proches il avait
le talent Gaspard prou il a le talent
après à un moment est sur une radio
privé C par ailleurs il est sur une
chaîne privée ça regarde ça regarde
group on peut pas muser quelqu'un parce
qu'il est
nul il est en contravention et Monsieur
l'administrateur vous pouvez nous le
dire il est en contravention avec
l'article 5 de la
Charte juste je voudrais la citer la
société participe aux actions en faveur
de la cohésion sociale et de la lut
contre les discriminations il est en
violation avec cette avec ce avec ce
principe là avec cet article là à ce
titre il devrait être sanctionné à
minima ce qui est compliqué ce que vous
dites c'est que il y a l'expression
qu'on fait en humoriste dans un sketch
ou dans une antenne à un moment donné
dans une chronique et il y a ensuite le
prolongement sur les réseaux sociaux
c'està direire que aujourd'hui la
complexité c'est que à côté de la parole
humoristique que moi j'ai trouvé déplacé
mais c'est pas le sujet il y a un
prolongement sur les réseaux sociaux
avec des expressions politiques et moi
c'est ce que j'ai dit c'est quelque
chose alors de plus mesuré peut-être
mais c'est qu'il faut faire la
différence à un moment donné soit on est
humoriste soit on est militant politique
si on est militant politique on s'engage
on se prend aux élections et on est
candidat on peut pas se servir c'est ça
mon argument il est pas très on peut pas
se servir de l'humour comme d'une
tribune politique Gaspar prou il reste
je pense pas qu'il prétend être un
militant politique l'humour est militant
mais à travers ceour on peut lire ses
opinions
politiques comme FA et et mais là ce que
je comprends pas en fait c'est que il a
un tel CV effectivement sur les réseaux
sociaux un moment donné quand on
l'engage on c'est exactement à qui on a
affaire non on a on a son profil et on
le prend quand même donc en fait on
l'engage pourquoi pour finalement on
peut l'engager en considérant que c'est
que c'est un humour particulier qui nous
peut-être pas mais qu'il a un humour
particulier après depuis qu'il est
effectivement en fonction on voit qu'il
prend des position politique et c'est là
mon sujet mais même cavrivère
cavrivierère aussi si je peux me
permettre cavrivière aussi parfois on
peut
l mais ça aprs c'est une question de
pointement ce ce qu' dit Monsieur le
Député dit Monsieur le Député c'est pas
se
vouszp ils sont pas sur les réseaue la
journée à faire des TW politiqu
exactement ils sont pas en campagne
idéologique ils traitent du sujet du
jour que ce soit Philippe cavrier ou
Gaspar prou ils sont pas toute la
journée sur sur les r ils sont pas toute
la journée sur les réseaux à faire de la
propagande la propagande politique je
suis pas d'accord sur la directrice de
France Inter vous avez vu sa
réponse alors euh est-ce que sa réponse
vous convient Gill vous avez dit que
c'était une réponse molle molle c'est
des mots mais en tant qu'administrateur
euh est-ce que vous ne demandez pas une
mise à pied ou euh un départ de ce
pseudo humorist pas partir est-ce qu'il
va pas partir au-delà de Guillaume
Meuris moi j'ai demandé pardon de me
répéter mais j'ai demandé une vraie
clarification on voit dans le service
public ou ailleurs des humoristes qui
sont des pseudochroniqueurs qui se
disent humoristes mais qui en fait
derrière ont une idéologie qu'ils
essayent de de distiller à travers
l'humour et moi je demande une
clarification plus large c'est pas la
question de Guillaume meurrice et c'est
aussi pour ça que je suis là parce que
c'est un débat essentiel les médias vous
êtes les premiers à être confrontés on a
appelé à boycotter votre émission c'est
pas un petit sujet c'est derrière
Guillaume meis c'est un sujet majeur un
la pluralité de l'information dans notre
pays la liberté d'expression qui est
important et à force d'y mettre des
coups on porte préjudice à des émissions
comme la vôtre au service public à
France interre il y a des journalistes à
France interre qui font un boulot
remarquable couvrir l'actualité au
Proche Orient couvrir l'actualité au
Proche Orient c'est pas facile on est un
pays qui qui est en tension le moindre
mot le moindre mot est éped et moi je
sais que les journalistes de France
Inter essayent des journalistes essayent
de couvrir cette actualité en étant le
plus équilibré possible en essayant de
pas prendre position de dire les faits
c'est pas évident j'étais en Israël moi
j'ai vu l'horreur de mes yeux j'ai vu la
barbarie et ensuite il faut être capable
de prendre du recul et de manière
objective de décrire des faits c'est pas
évident et donc moi j'appelle à de la
modération vous savez ce qui meérange le
plus dans ce qu'a fait Guillaume Meurice
c'est qu'il alimente un moment de notre
pays où la société fracturé est-ce qu'on
est obligé de brutaliser le débat public
vous avez des désaccords je vous regarde
de temps en temps ça m'arrive vous
donnez votre avis mais est-ce qu'on est
obligé en permanence d'avoir la terreur
des mots la brutalisation de la vie
politique est-ce qu'on est obligé de
dire qu'Israël est un État fasciste les
mots ont un sens donc on le sanctionne
bah oui donc on le vire donc on prend
des mesures fortes et je fais confiance
et je le dis ici je fais confiance à la
présidente directrice générale de Radio
France pour prendre les mesures qui
seront utiles mais c'est des mesures
plus importantes le problème de
Guillaume muris c'est que ça arrive à un
moment donné où tout nous expose à la
figure où on voit bien que ces débats
qui couvent la politisation d'une partie
des humoristes des chroniqueur ça fait
des années qu'on en parle c'est un vrai
sujet bah c'est maintenant qu' faut y
répondre on va pas en faire un héros on
va pas en faire un héros si on le
sanctionne et si on le on et puis
humoriste ou pas humoriste politique ou
pas politique pardon mais il y a un
dérapage antisémite et on ne peut pas
cautionner ça sur un plateau le service
public a viré un animateur pour une
blague de très mauvais goût sur un sujet
qui n'avait rien à voir et là on garde à
l'antenne quel
sa blague était était atroce mais je
trouve ça si on peut se permettre de
faire une échelle moins grave qu'un
dérappage antisémite dans cette période
et mettez-vous à la place de n'importe
qui qui tiendrait ce ses propos sur un
plateau c'est la porte direct pourquoi
on garde ce mec là on en fait limite une
star parce que c'est pas une question de
ce qu'on dit c'est une question est-ce
qu'il était sorti de son rôle
d'humoriste on parlait de Gaspar pr ou
est-ce que ça devient du militantiste
politique et qu'on juge ses propos comme
t après après est-ce que je peux je peux
vous dire moi moi je je lis tout ce qui
arrive donc je vous pose la question
parce qu'il y a plein de gens qui
réagissent sur les réseaux et qui disent
moi je suis pas d'accord il faut pas
sanctionner Guillaume MCE parce que il y
a énormément même d'Israéliens qui sont
contre la politique
de et qui il a pas ils disent il ne
s'est pas attaqué au peuple juif mais au
Premier ministre qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ça moi j'ai lu il y a
beaucoup de gens qui disent ça moi j'ai
lu sur Twitter une comparaison où on
insinuait que Israël était un État
fasciste être en disaccord avec la
politique de Benyamin netanahou
considérer qu'aujourd'hui la guerre est
peut-être trop importante et que il faut
protéger les civils palestiniens éviter
les dommages collatéraux tout ça ce sont
des opinions tout à fait légitimes mais
quand un humoriste lui comme un autre
parle d'État fasciste il faut faire
attention à ce qu'on l'on dit
aujourd'hui on peut pas faire semblant
de pas voir que l'antisionisme la haine
d'Israël et le nouveau visage de
l'antisémitisme faut être aveugle pour
pas le voir vous avez vu ces jeunes dans
le métro qu'est-ce qu'ils disent ils
disent nique Israël nique les Juifs
c'est comme ça l'antisionisme la haine
d'Israël et aujourd'hui nouveau visage
de l'antisémitisme et donc il faut faire
attention on peut dire je ne suis pas
d'accord avec la politique de Benyamine
netanahou on peut dire qu'on ne
cautionne pas ce qu'il est en train de
faire à Gaza mais ça ne veut pas dire
que Israël est un État fasciste
attention au mots qu'on emploie il y a
des jeunes qui nous regardent il faut
être capable d'AV c'est la
responsabilité d'un service public que
de ne pas non plus sortir du cadre il
est pas il est pas dans le cadre de
l'humour il est dans un cadre où où il
donne une opinion politique en
assimilant néaniaou à un nazi en faisant
référence au prépus qui nous renvoie à
la période de l'occupation je ve dire ce
sont des termes qui sont extrêmement
graves on n pas dans un cadre d'humour
on est dans un cadre plus que militant
ça on peut pas le tolérer sur une chaîne
de service pour ça que je suis venu ici
aussi pour dire comme administrateur de
Radio France et ne pas me cacher que les
équipes de Radio France de France Inter
font un boulot remarquable les
journalistes font un boulot remarquable
c'est pas facile du tout d' aussi être
garant de la cohésion sociale de la
cohésion en France
je vais vous dire un truc et c'est ce
que dit Monsieur le Député euh sachez
qu'aujourd'hui euh c'est vrai voilà il y
a des journalistes exceptionnel sur le
service public voilà et ils sont un
petit peu gênés aussi euh par par ce qui
se passe autour de et il le rend pas
service ils sont un petit peu voilà pare
qu'il y a des
petites évidemment que ça coince parce
que il jette le discrédit sur
effectivement une rédaction qui bosse
comme elle peut est-ce que vous pensez
pas qu'il va partir de lui-même moi je
pense que là il se pose des questions il
est dans une surenchère il cherche une
peut-être une porte de sortie par le
haut comme il va pouvoir faire en
insultant le RN et cetera on sent qu'il
est un peu perdu moi je pense qu'il n
luctablement peut-être qu'il finira la
saison mais en tout cas je le vois pas
rester sur France interre et je pense
que Monsieur le Député vous voyez pas
non plus un avenir à terme pour Monsieur
mauris sur France interre je vois que la
présidente directrice générale de Radio
France décidera mais vous avez bien
compris mon point c'est un sujet plus
large c'est un sujet plus large que
guillaumeuris c'est ce sujet majeur à un
moment donné je me répète mais des des
éditorialistes politiques c'est pas des
humoristes faut choisir son mé humorist
sont pas des journalistes non plus parce
que le parallèle on des journalistes
formidables ça c'est vrai sur le terrain
mais un humoriste c'est pas un
journaliste il donne son avis moi je me
pose juste une question est-ce que le
fait qu'il ne s'excuse pas qu'il refuse
de s'excuser ça ne jette pas davantage
de l'huile sur le feu parce que faire
effectivement un parallèle qui est
inacceptable et moi je suis d'accord
avec tout ce qui a été dit c'est une
chose c'est un dérapage mais le fait
d'en rajou ter une couche en disant je
refuse de m'excuser est-ce que ça ne
devient pas inadmissible je je vous ai
dit ce que j'en pense la société est en
tension je la vois comme député vous la
voyez mais regardez les manifestations
regardez la multiplication des actes
antisémites et je pense que à un moment
donné sans se renier on peut être
capable de dire je suis allé trop loin
en fait moi je j'aime beaucoup Patrick
Timsit il a fait des blagues horribles
sur les personnes en situation de
handicap c'était son droit il est
humoriste à un moment donné il a vu les
mois il a pris la parole il a dit
écoutez à aucun moment je ne voulais
vous visez c'est de l'humour c'était
malencontreux c'était maladroit je pense
qu'un humoriste sans se déshonorer sans
se renier peut être capable de dire j'ai
poussé le bouchon sa pierre des proche
disait on a besoin des humoristes en
temps de guerre il y a une forme de
catarcis moy j'ai vu l'horreur je vois
dans les camps les camps de Chura où
j'ai vu les bébés israéliens assassiné
je l'ai vu de mes yeux d'avoir de
l'humour ça paraît peut-être incohérent
ce que je dis mais on a besoin d'artiste
on a besoin d'humoriste pour essayer de
de nous aider à traverser ces périodes
et donc quand un
humoriste fait des propos qui finalement
contribue à mettre le pays en tension ça
a des conséquences regardez on est en
débat c'est pas drôle ce qu'il a dit il
faut être capable de s'excuser il faut
être capable de s'excuser drôle ex
gasparous drôle dépres est drôle et
Philippe car Rivierre est très drôle je
suis désolé voilà mais le problème c'est
pasil est drô pas drôle le problème
c'est est-ce qu'il est homme politique
ou est-ce qu'il est humoriste et
effectivement dire qu'il estah oui mais
vous savez on a une classe politique
aujourd'hui qui n'a pas voulu nommer par
exle des attentats et qui a laissé
justement le trucement 71